uh do you worry about the audience
capture aspect of it because it is a
platform for conservatives
and you have a powerful voice on there
there it might be difficult for you to
go against
the talking points or against the stream
of ideas that is usually connected to
conservative thought do you worry about
that I mean the audience would obviously
be upset with me and would have a right
to be upset with me if I suddenly
flipped all my positions on a dime I
have enough faith in my audience that I
can say things that I think are true and
that made us agree with the audience
you know on a fairly regular basis I
would say um but they understand that on
the deeper principle we're on the same
side of the at least I hope that much
from the audience it's also why we
provide a number of different views on
the platforms many of which I disagree
with but are sort of within the
generalized range of conservative
thought and that I I you know it's
something I I do have to think about
every day though yeah I mean you have to
you have to think about like am I saying
this because I'm afraid of taking off my
audience or am I saying this because I
actually believe this and you know
that's a that's a delicate dance a
little bit you have to be sort of honest
with yourself
yeah somebody like um Sam Harris is
pretty good at this at fighting at
saying the the most outrageous thing
that he knows he almost leans into it he
knows will piss off a lot of his
audience
um sometimes you almost have to test the
system
um it's like if you feel you almost
exaggerate your feelings just to make
sure to send a signal to the audience
that you're not captured by them